the number remains six one seven eight
three zero four seven five zero a lot of
interesting call so far who's joining me
now Josh from New Jersey how are you
today but good what can we do for you
today well I have a question somewhat
regarding Trump I know you're probably
sick of hearing about them this is
something I've been thinking about a lot
recently okay before you ask it Louis
are we able to turn up the volume in my
headphone so I don't want to miss a
second of this question okay go ahead
okay so I think at this point in Trump's
campaign pretty much any level-headed
person can objectively agree it's pretty
exacting pretty silly yeah but my
question is like you know I know people
that regardless of all this still
support them yeah and you know in the
past it's kind of like you know you
don't want to be that one guy who stops
being friends and like a close friend
because of their political beliefs but I
think that this dude you know Trump is
something totally different because it's
not really like a political belief
because they yeah it kind of goes deeper
than I know what I mean like people take
it way too far
oh yeah no you're bringing up a good
point and I've thought about this
because you know if somebody says to me
listen I'm for Romney because just
growing up I was I was sort of like the
pro-business you know I really get
Romney and I'm not really extreme on
social issues but I'm also not like a
big social issues person where I'm going
to go out and lobby so I'm gonna vote
Romney but we can get along and it's all
we're reasonable people in whatever the
extent to which Trump has been just
showing himself to be so clueless and
and the entire thing is completely
farcical in nature I've said many times
now that to vote for Trump you must be
some combination of ignorant apathetic
mentally deficient or a genuinely bad
person and I think it is it has never
been more true of any candidate than
with Trump and no doubt I mean I know a
few people Louis who I found out are
voting for Trump that I know personally
I haven't necessarily spoken with them
about it I can't take anything seriously
I mean okay I had some
gap when they if they said I'm voting
Romney but it's nothing compared to yeah
I'm actually gonna go and cast a vote
for Trump yeah it's it's I mean a a deep
fundamental ideological difference
between you and your friend what it
sounds like here and I you know on a
certain level of course the two of you
are friends for a reason
you still connect in some way and I
still think you can put this aside if if
the two of you are aware that it's you
should just never discuss politics with
one another unless though let me throw
out I like what Louis is saying and with
some of my friends we just don't talk
about politics because we know we
disagree but there's sort of reasonable
disagreements do you feel like like
you're like there's such an intellectual
and ideological canyon between you and
someone who would vote Trump that you
just couldn't possibly even take
seriously anything they say whether it's
regarding politics or not like is it
that serious in your mind well here's
the thing it's confusing because you
know friends that I'm talking about
he's pretty you know liberal and
open-minded in terms of you know other
things and other interests and he
researches politics I guess but I feel
like we've got those people the research
isn't only in terms of like one
viewpoint and yeah I know chamber I
don't really talk back that much but
like there's all this stupid stuff that
chump is just saying it's kind of hard
not to not to talk about you know yeah
no I get it I get it
yeah well that's tough but let us know
how it works out I have a feeling that
the Trump campaign will result in a lot
of ended friendships and relationships I
can only imagine what a trump presidency
would result in thanks so much for the
call I know a lot of people in the
audience probably struggling with pretty
similar issues appreciate the call